- Our next guest is a
talented actress you know
from hit shows like "Crazy Ex-Girlfriend".
You can also catch her on
the complete first season
of "Mr. Mayor", which is
now streaming on Peacock.
Check it out.
- Statistically, we should
be married by age 29.5
and I'll need at least a year
for my mom to lose the weight.
- What are you saying, Tommy?
- We are going to meet our
spouses in this building.
- No, here?
The pool is too small.
I don't wanna be a step-mom to a possum.
- It's a sugar glider, idiot.
- How are we supposed to meet anyone here?
- Please welcome Vella Lovell!
(applause and cheers)
(upbeat music)
- Air hugs!
- I love your dress!
- Thank you so much.
- You look beautiful.
I wish I were as tall
as you as well, okay.
- No.
- No, I really do.
I'm 5'3".
- You really don't.
- It's nice to meet you!
- So nice to meet you.
- That was hilarious, the clip.
Is this just such a fun cast to work with?
- It's so much fun.
Yeah, it's crazy.
I have to pinch myself all
the time because I'm like,
it feels like TV royalty
that I get to work with.
- Yeah, and I feel like
you just laugh on set
probably all day long,
- Yeah, all the time.
I'm always the first person to break too.
I'm always like, keep it together.
- Oh my gosh, I'm not good at that.
I had to do SNL and I was like,
how am I supposed to not laugh right now?
When they're trying
to make you laugh.
- Yeah like this is hilarious.
This is funny,
I'm gonna laugh.
- It's hard.
Yes.
I heard something about you though
that we have a similarity.
My mom was single for quite some time too
and a teacher.
- Yes, I know!
- And you grew up with a
single mom that's a teacher.
- I know, it made me feel so,
I was like, oh, Kelly gets it.
- Yeah.
Well, I get being poor because teachers
make no money.
- Definitely, yes, exactly!
Pay teachers more, definitely.
- And you watch your mom just kill it.
My mom was such a hard worker.
- Yeah, and like doing a
million things at the same time.
- [Kelly] Multitasking.
- You also like never
get away with anything
because there's no one to be like, well,
that parent said no, but
what about that parent?
My mom was like, no, I said no.
- So where did you grow up?
- I grew up in Santa
Fe, New Mexico mostly.
- Beautiful.
- Yeah, it's a pretty
weird town, I have to say.
- Is it? I love it.
I visited, I love it.
- Have you really?
- Yeah!
- Oh, amazing.
What did you do?
- I was there because a
friend was shooting something
and I was there for that reason.
- Well what's so crazy is when
I was growing up, I was like,
I have to get out of
here, which now I'm like,
maybe that's more about teenagers
than actually about
where we grow up.
- 100%
- But yeah. I was like, I
have to get to the big city,
but now like all of these
film projects are filming
in New Mexico and I'm
like, this is so wild.
Like my PE teacher works
in the film industry now.
I'm like, well, that's cool.
- What?
- Yeah, it's a big thing there now.
- It's funny though, how we
wanna escape where we're from
and then all of a sudden, like,
all I crave is a small town.
- Yeah, totally.
- I love a small town.
- And now I love going back home.
And like, it has a totally
kind of eclectic art scene
and like George R.R. Martin
who wrote "Game of Thrones"
lives in Santa Fe, which
kind of gives you an insight.
- And the shopping is awesome.
You have such cool stores like antiques-
- Lots of turquoise.
- Yes, I love turquoise.
Well don't they have a crazy,
like the art scene.
Were you always into that
like when you were a kid?
- Yeah.
- Were you always artistic?
- Yeah, definitely.
I definitely grew up and wanted to,
like loved being in
plays and I played piano
when I was young.
I thought I was gonna be
like a concert pianist.
- Oh, you were good.
- Yeah, well, my mom, I think
when I was little noticed
I had like a lot of nervous
energy with my hands
and was like, "My
grandparents have a piano,
so we're just gonna put
her in piano lessons."
So I thought I was gonna
be like a classical pianist
until I was like, till I went to college.
And then I kind of discovered
acting and realized,
all right, life choices.
- Life choices.
(laughter)
- And I feel like your mind kind of like,
you kind of have weird goggles in New York
where you're like, I'm
sharing a one bedroom
with eight people, but it's amazing.
(laughter)
You're just like, this
is such a great deal!
And I like I shower in the
sink, but it's so great.
- It's so fun.
Well congrats on season
two of "Mr. Mayor".
This is awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- So for everybody that hasn't seen it,
can you say who you play?
- Yes.
So I play I'm Mikaela and I am
Ted Danson's chief of staff.
So dream role and yeah,
Ted Danson plays the mayor of
LA who like unexpectedly won
to impress his teenage daughter.
And I play, I was his campaign manager
during the campaign.
And then all of a sudden he
makes me his chief of staff.
So like, Mikaela is
completely out of her depth.
She's like never worked
in public office before
and she's running the
whole administration.
So it's a really fun-
- Terrifying,
it's terrifying.
- Yeah, it's terrifying.
Yeah, totally.
It's a fun character to play though.
'Cause I feel like she's
just posing and she's like,
I know what I'm doing, but I
have no idea what I'm doing.
- Yeah, but I am gonna bull
(beep) my way through this.
- Yes, I'm gonna fake it
until somebody notices.
- That's all we do.
- Yeah. That's what life is, right?
- Well, everybody, the complete
first season of "Mr. Mayor"
is now available to stream on Peacock.
You gotta check it out.